jóvenes estudiantes se abrigan como
pueden y se dirigen a clase en kabul
pero no son tantos como de costumbre
durante la madrugada y la noche hace
tanto frío que la mayoría de nuestros
alumnos no pueden venir
desde el invierno más frío en Afganistán
en 15 años con temperaturas que
descienden hasta los 32 grados bajo cero
matando a más de 100 personas y
agravando una crisis económica y
humanitaria más amplia
esto en un contexto de seis millones de
personas es un número asombroso de
personas Llamando a la puerta de la
hambruna en condiciones parecidas a la
hambruna
el mes pasado las autoridades talibanes
ordenaron a las ongs que impidieran
trabajar a la mayoría del personal
femenino esto ha llevado a muchas
agencias de ayuda a suspender sus
operaciones en las últimas semanas
provocando la respuesta de los talibanes
se trata de un acto de cru organizado
por las Naciones Unidas y es inaceptable
en la ONU hay una ley que dice que hay
que Mostrar respeto a todas las personas
y a todas las religiones nuestra
religión no permite que las mujeres
trabajen de esa manera
el miércoles la ONU declaró que los
talibanes habían concedido algunas
excepciones a la prohibición y que la
comunidad humanitaria estaba negociando
con ellos para intentar conseguir más a
fin de permitir que las trabajadoras
siguieran prestando una ayuda vital en
un momento de crisis humanitaria sin
precedentes